[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Please put
your hands together.
Welcome to the stage
Peter Godfrey-Smith.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER GODFREY-SMITH: OK.
This talk will be a
fast underwater tour
of animal evolution,
and in particular
the evolution of the mind.
The first fact here,
I think, is the fact
that the mind evolved
in the sea this idea has
several sides to it.
Firstly, just the fact that
for all the early stages,
the first and crucial period,
until about 400 million years
ago, just about all life and
all animal life was in the sea.
That was the context.
And in that period before a life
on land, most of the essentials
were laid down.
So the evolution of
animals themselves,
the evolution of nervous systems
and brains, the evolution
of complex senses such
as eyes and of bodies
that can act in complex ways.
And to some extent, all
the rest is fine-tuning.
Now, I'm not saying that
everything was in place
before we came up on land.
Mammals certainly have special
features, as do humans.
But the basics are in place.
And the question
that then arises
is whether what was
in place included
those aspects of the
mind that philosophers
have found most mysterious,
subjective experience
and consciousness.
Now, this is a famously
difficult question,
but I think we can work
towards answering it
and I think the answer
to the question is yes.
Now, one more aspect to the
idea that the mind evolved
in the sea is related
to that last point.
So when you think about how it's
even possible for a physical
system to have mental states,
especially experiences,
part of what makes this
problem seem so hard, I think--
so hard that people
despair of it--
is the fact that people
have a particular picture
of the physical in
their heads when
they think about this
aspect of the problem.
They have a kind of dry
land macroscopic picture
of the physical and how
physical things interact.
Or perhaps they have in mind the
particular kinds of interaction
you find within
present day computers
with a processor
or many processors,
various kinds of memory,
and a cascade of read
and write operations.
Now, I think this
is part of what has
steered people the wrong way--
not so much the computational
electronic picture
of the material, and I think
that's an interesting topic
to think about here at Google,
but the more general picture
of the physical and the earlier
mechanistic conception I think
has been a significant
source of trouble here.
Instead, we should think about
the distinctive properties
of cellular life, the
particular kinds of goings
on within cells.
It's an acquiesce environment
and a nano scale environment.
Everything is in
water in solution,
there's continual
spontaneous activity.
And the way things
get done within a cell
is by means of
essentially a multitude
of biased random walks.
So the physical itself
is different in the sea
and in cells.
Now, I'm not saying
that's itself
enough to remove
all mystery, but I
think it's important to
think in the right way
about the biological
basis of the mind
as we think about this problem.
And when animals
moved up on land,
this is an animal that has
not yet moved off on land,
they took all this with them.
They hauled up in their cells
the chemistry of the sea
where they came from.
Now, as the title
of my book suggests,
we're working towards
the special role
in the story of octopuses
and other cephalopods,
but we're not there yet.
The next thing to think
about is the overall shape
of the history of animal life.
Now, life in general
forms the shape
of a tree, roughly speaking.
So from a single root, a series
of branching events usually
with no rejoinings extend
to the present day.
There are branchings
and then divergence.
This process began with
single-celled life.
We don't know the
original forms,
but based on what we know about
single-celled organisms now,
the picture to have
in your mind is not
little cells that are
self-contained little islands,
but systems that are
open to the world,
sensing and responding,
exhibiting behavior,
including even social
behavior, on a tiny scale.
Now, animals are one branch
of multicellular life.
And the first way to
think about animals
is they are one pretty big
branch of the tree of life,
a branch that comes off around
900 million years ago or so,
perhaps.
And in that transition
to multicellular life,
the sensing and
signaling that cells
had been doing as whole
organisms in the unicellular
state is now used to
coordinate activities
of cells within the
new collective entities
that had arisen, making
possible coordinated
and coherent action.
So the social behavior of
cells becomes the means
for all animal action.
Now, there's no fossil record
of the very earliest stages.
The first stages of the
history of animal life
that we do have a
fossil record of
are from the Ediacaran Period,
roughly 635 to 540 million
years ago.
This is a photo of a typical
Ediacaran fossil in the South
Australian Museum and it's
the sort of round thing
that is the likely animal
fossil, something that looks
a little bit like a bathmat.
So life was very
different back then.
All animals were
soft-bodied and life also
seems to have been fairly quiet.
This is, I think, a
gorgeous reconstruction
of Ediacaran life by the
English artist John Sibbick.
And one of the
distinctive things
that this sort of
illustration captures
is the fact that animals--
well, it's not even clear
which of these living things
were animals--
but animals in
particular don't seem
to have had too much
to do with each other.
Many of them probably
didn't move around at all.
So that's the first stage.
And now I want to start to
place all this into a larger
historical context
also looking forward.
So there is a summary
picture of part of the animal
branch of the tree of life.
This is from the book.
So with all these tree pictures,
you should think of time
as running up the screen.
And so we have a series
of branchings giving rise
to, at the top, various
different present day
kinds of organisms--
vertebrates there on the left;
mollusks, including cephalopods,
which I'll talk about shortly;
arthropods, including
insects; then you
get things like jelly
fish and sponges.
And the next thing
to note is that many
of the deep branchings
in animal evolution
took place in the
Ediacaran Period.
That's when the sort of
separations occurred.
Now, here's another
picture not from the book,
from another paper of mine.
What the orange band
there represents
is the fact that the deep
historical branchings giving
rise to the various
present day groups,
those branchings took
place in the Ediacaran,
at this time of very
limited interaction.
A particularly important
animal living at that time
might have looked
something like this.
This is a sort of little
worm-like creature.
There's no fossil
record, this is very much
a sort of tentative
reconstruction.
But it was something
like the first animal
that had left-right symmetry
as part of its body plan.
It had a left and right, as
well as a top and bottom.
And this body plan
evolved in the Ediacaran.
Most of the animals
that we're familiar with
are bilaterians animals,
they have that kind
of left-right plant that
was originally laid down
in something like this.
This was probably a very
small animal, quite simple.
It did have a nervous
system, almost certainly,
but a simple nervous
system, most likely.
So on a slide like that,
we have that animal
placed at its particular
moment in the tree
and everything downstream
sort of on its branch
is a bilaterally symmetrical
organism, including ourselves
and animals like octopuses.
So the branchings
occurred earlier,
before what's known as
the Cambrian Explosion.
Then in the Cambrian,
life changed dramatically.
Rather than soft
bodied-animals that
look a bit like
macaroons or bathmats,
you'd have animals that
looked something like this.
You'd have hard
parts-- spines, claws;
you'd have complex
sensory mechanisms,
especially complex eyes.
And it is very
likely that this is
when animals began to have much
more to do with each other,
especially as
predators and prey.
From there, you get lots
of downstream evolution
and this takes us
through something
that can be roughly summarized
with a picture like this.
Lots of animals come from
this early bilaterian lineage,
and in a few groups you have
the evolution of large brains
and complex behavior.
You have firstly the
evolution of large brains
and complex behavior in our
group, in the vertebrates.
Many vertebrates are like this,
especially mammals and birds.
And in what we informally
refer to as invertebrates,
all the others, you
mostly have animals
that have small nervous systems
and relatively simple behavior,
but with one big
exception, the cephalopods,
a group of mollusks.
Here we have a large
nervous system, one
in the vertebrate range--
roughly 500 million neurons
in the case of an octopus--
and the most recent common
ancestor of you on one side
and an octopus on the
other, with its very large
nervous system, was that very
simple worm-like creature
living in the Ediacaran
600 million years ago.
So what we really have
is independent evolution
from that point down
two sides and something
we can think of as two
independent evolutionary
experiments in the origin
of large nervous systems
and complex brains.
So a cephalopod is--
we're looking at the results
of the one experiment
outside our line in the
evolution of a large, really
large nervous system.
And I think this,
consequently, as the closest
we'll ever come to meeting
an intelligent alien.
When I say that, I
mean the following.
If you think about what it
would be like to meet an alien,
the big fact about
an alien is that it's
an intelligent form of life that
has no common ancestor with us
at all, coming from a totally
separate evolutionary lineage.
An octopus is certainly
not like that,
but the common ancestor is
so far away and probably
quite simple, and as a
result, most of what we see
arose independently in the
roughly 600 million years ago
since that common ancestor.
So what did we get on the other
side and why did we get it?
Well, we get a mixture of
similarities and differences
from things like our cells.
The most conspicuous
similarity between a cephalopod
and a vertebrate is the eye.
Cephalopods independently
evolved a camera eye.
So this is a giant
cuttlefish, which
has the same kind of eye
as an octopus, a camera
eye with a lens that focuses
an image on a retina.
You also have various
sophisticated kinds
of learning.
And lastly, something
that was really
the beginning of my own
fascination with these animals,
there's a kind of engagement
that these animals display
when you interact with them.
The first ones I came across
myself were not octopuses,
but giant cuttlefish
like this guy here.
This animal was probably sort
of between two and three feet
long, they're not small.
I was snorkeling
near Sydney and saw
under a ledge something
moving around,
went down and had a look at it.
And as I thought
from the surface,
it was a large animal and
something very active.
And the two most
striking things about it
were firstly, the astounding
array of color changes
that it was producing
as I watched it.
These animals can change the
entire color of their skin
in much less than a second.
And secondly, the
fact that this animal
seemed about as interested
in me as I was in it.
There's a kind of a
feeling of meeting
you can have with these animals,
which is, I take it unique,
when a person meets another
invertebrate and quite rare
when we meet any animal.
Just to give you a sense of
the capacity for color change,
these two photographs were
taken four seconds apart.
So a giant cuttlefish
can completely
transform it skin to that
yellow in less than a second
and then take it back
to that reddish pattern
a few seconds later.
And this image also
gives you a sense
of the fact that it's not
just whole colors that they
can produce, but very complex
stripes and bands, dynamic
as well as static
patterns, as well.
So how did there
come to be animals
that could do these things?
Let's talk a little bit
about the cephalopod brain
and the kind of being
that these animals are.
So as I said, there are
roughly 500 million neurons
in an octopus.
The number is not really
known for cuttlefish,
but they may have even
a slightly higher ratio
of brain weight to body
weight than octopuses have.
The big difference
between them and us
is the fact that more than half
of the neurons in an octopus
are not where you would expect
to find them, in the head,
but spread through the body,
especially within the arms
themselves.
And each of the arms appears
to have some degree of autonomy
as a kind of quasi agent.
Now, how did this
come to happen?
We can put some
of it into context
by looking at the
lives that were lived
and the history of
this particular group.
So here's is a
reconstruction of what
an early-ish ancestor of
present day cephalopods
might have looked like
back in the Paleozoic.
This is a large
shelled predator.
At some point in
animal evolution,
the shells were abandoned
and what you were left with
was a body with a kind
of immense flexibility.
You should think, by the
way, about an octopus'
arms or a cuttlefish's
arms not so much as arms,
but really as kind of
eight or 10 enormous lips.
And those enormous
multi-shaped lips
are extremely useful things
if you can control them,
but they are extremely
difficult things to control.
Now, in us when we
move, our joints
give our movements guidance.
You don't have to tell your
every detail about where to go.
In an octopus with no joints
and no hard parts at all,
the arm can be essentially
any shape and length.
So you would either
have to specify
exactly the fine details
of all its motions
or give the arm a
little bit of freedom
to work out the details
of its motions itself.
And it does seem
that there has been
a sort of partial
delegation of control
to the arms of an
octopus by evolution.
Each arm has many senses.
Whenever an octopus
touches you, it's
tasting you, as well
as feeling your shape.
And they seem to
sort of determine
at least the details of many
of the emotions themselves
and also engage in a kind
of exploration on their own.
So here are a couple
of photos that give you
a sense of the contrast here.
So firstly, we have
two screen shots
from a video in which
this octopus is reaching
aggressively for another one.
And in a shot like
this, the arm seems
very much like a
sort of tool directed
by the animal as a whole.
It's reaching with
one arm for this guy,
and in this case
successfully seizing it.
This kind of picture gives
the opposite impression.
I don't have a video of this
sequence, unfortunately, just
an image.
But it's an octopus and it's
sitting there doing nothing
in particular.
And one of the
arms, the red arrow
there indicates
the extent of it,
has just kind of wandered
off in a way that
looked to me as if it was
apparently more or less
self-directed, a kind
of exploratory behavior
by the arm on its own.
Now, given all this,
a natural question
to ask next is, what might
it be like to be an octopus?
Is it like anything
to be an octopus?
Look I think-- these questions
are, of course, very hard
to answer.
I think the answer, does
it feel like something
to be an octopus is yes.
The harder question is
how to address rigorously
a problem of that kind.
Now, the first thing
to note, I think,
is that a reasonable view
has it that a certain kind
of experience in
animals just comes
with a certain
degree of complexity
in sensing and responding
and acting upon the world.
That runs deep in
animal evolution.
Octopuses are exemplars
of that kind of capacity.
Another more specific thing I
think it's worth looking for
is evidence of things like pain.
So lots of what might
look superficially
like pain-related behaviors
in various animals,
especially invertebrates,
are probably or possibly
quite misleading.
They may not be good
indicators of felt pain,
of the kind of interior
sensation of the sort that
comprises pain in us.
So then the question
arises, how can you
look for a behavior that
shows something non-reflexive,
something that's indicative
or suggestive at least that it
feels like something to be
an animal of a certain kind
in pain?
And one good example that's
been looked at in several groups
recently is wound tending.
You can ask the question, which
animals will tend a damaged
part, protect it from being
touched by other objects
and stimuli as time goes on?
We got an interesting series of
shots of an octopus exhibiting
pain-related behavior.
This is in some ways a
sort of comical shot,
not so much for the
octopus I think.
This was a large
aggressive octopus
who was trying to dominate
a particular site I'll
talk about shortly.
And one of the things he did
in his attempts to dominate
was raise his rear end
very high above his body
in these sort of size displays.
And in one particular
occasion when
he raised his rear
end very high,
a fish came in and
bit him really hard
right on the end
of his body there.
And you can see the fish biting.
These fish, by the way,
are very unpleasant to bite
even if you're a person.
I've been bitten by
them and it's not nice.
The octopus behaved
exactly like a person,
sort of with this very startled
leap and arms going everywhere.
I was curious whether
he would tend the wound.
He did not.
Instead, he went back to
beating up other octopuses.
So an octopus has sort of
reasonably good evidence,
I think, of various kinds
of subjective experience.
The special elements
and the question
I think that's
particularly intriguing
here concerns what
kind of sense of self
there might be in an
animal of this kind
and how different that
would be in an octopus
and in a more neurally
centralized animal
like ourselves.
So we can ask which
activities an octopus engages
in are experienced
as my actions,
as authored by the individual,
as opposed to things that just
happen and are observed
by the central animal
by means of those
semi-agent-like arms?
In a talk I gave last week, a
grad student at the University
of Pennsylvania made a
suggestion that seemed obvious
in retrospect, that I hadn't
thought about it much before,
which is, well, there need
not be a single answer
to this question.
It might be that
when an octopus is
doing a very sort of focused
intentional behavior,
like that reach in
the photo I had there,
then there's a kind of
single agent-like subjective
experience.
But that might sort of lapse
or fall away and be replaced
by a more distributed,
less self-like entity
when you're seeing individual
exploration by the arms.
So these are some
of the questions
that we'd like to
ask, a sort of mixture
of philosophical and scientific
questions about these animals.
And work is continuing on this.
In the last part
of this talk, what
I'll do is just show some
shots and some videos
from a particular site where a
lot of these photos were taken,
an octopus site that
we call Octopolus,
which is written about in
some detail in the book.
This is a site on the
east coast of Australia.
OK.
Here's the first video.
Here we go.
This just gives you a
sense of what this site is
like on a sort of typical day.
You've got a large number
of shells on a shell bed
and various octopuses
who are in residence.
And what's believed about
octopuses in general
is they're not very
social animals.
It's unusual for them
to have to interact
with each other
in decent numbers.
But at this particular site
in Australia that we study,
they've essentially had
to learn to get along.
The view we have is that
it's a site where there's
an abundance of food but a great
scarcity of decent den sites.
And one particular
area, an area but that
was perhaps seeded by
a single human left
object of unknown origin,
provided a kind of seed
around which a
crystal-like growth
occurred whereby octopuses
came to live in large numbers.
And a lot of the time,
they engage in sort
of mild controlled aggression.
Occasionally, they engage
in more intense aggression.
So this animal on the
left here is, in fact,
the octopus who was
bitten on the rear end
by the fish we saw earlier.
And this is a sort of
typical day for him,
engaging in a series
of fights where
he attempts to control access to
this pretty large site, a site
about the size of his stage.
And he's appeared to be able,
so far as we can tell, determine
with some reliability
the sexes of individuals
coming on and off the site and
tried to exclude other males.
So he engaged in a series of
fights and much of the time
did succeed in excluding them.
A feature that's also
unique at this site
is a kind of signaling.
This is the kind of display I
talked about briefly earlier,
where animals who are aggressive
will go up very large and dark,
maximizing their
darkness and size.
And if you look closely
at the animal who
it is about to chase, you'll
see this animal has gone pale.
But more specifically,
you'll see
that it has done a color change
such that half of its body,
the half facing the
attacking octopus,
is a kind of high contrast
mottled sort of color
and the other half of
its body facing away
is a kind of simple camouflage.
Now, we're not sure
exactly why that is.
The sort of high contrast
pattern on the side facing
has a role in various
cephalopod behaviors
as a kind of sometimes
called a diematic display.
The idea is you show
this to a predator
and it might startle
the predator.
It's possible that it's
being sort of pressed
into service as an attempt
to, in a futile way,
startle this oncoming octopus.
However, many individuals
produce this display
when they're not
trying to run away,
but trying to kind of
creep onto the site
under the gaze of another animal
in a non-aggressive manner.
So we suspect that it may
have been pressed into service
as a kind of indicator of
non-aggressive tendencies
in these animals.
And then the question
arises, is this something
that isn't a widespread
but hitherto unseen
feature of this behavior
across the species,
or is it something
that just develops
into a particular peculiar
social milieu of this site?
Another thing that's an
unusual feature of this site
is what we've come to call a
kind of high five behavior.
So this octopus on the
right there is moving across
towards the others
and as it goes,
there will often be a kind of--
I originally called
this boxing, but now I
realize I was being too
pugilistic in my metaphors
and it might be a kind
of slap of recognition
or of something like indication
of roles on the site that
animals do by just
by sort of jabbing
at each other with their arms.
This is a picture of
me at the site trying
to fix a camera while
a whole bunch of stuff
goes on around me, none of
which I'm able to see going on.
So we only sometimes
successfully look at them.
They often quite
successfully observe us.
This is an octopus inspecting
one of the GoPro cameras,
possibly as a preliminary
to taking it apart.
So I'll stop there.
Happy to take a few questions.
I think you'll agree these are
truly fascinating and stunning
animals.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the
talk it was very, very
cool to see that.
So probably the most
remarkable thing
about the mammalian experiment
with intelligence, I would say,
is our incredible memories.
It's quite difficult to
imagine what my sense of self
would be like without
that kind of memory.
What kind of memory do
the cephalopods have?
PETER GODFREY-SMITH: There's
some interesting new work
on this in cuttlefish, which
is interesting particularly
in continuities between
the human and this case.
So in the case of
humans, there's
sort of a standard
distinction between forms
of memory, the sort
of memory of how
to do things, procedural
memory; what's
called semantic memory,
memory of facts, the fact
that Paris is the
capital of France.
And episodic memory is memory
of what happened to you,
of experiences.
And the kind of memory
that you were describing
as very sort of distinctive to
human experiences is that kind.
So a good question
is, which animals
might have something like
episodic memory, memory
not just of facts--
where things are-- but
of what experiences
I had when I was in that place?
And recently, some
work that's been
used to study episodic memory,
or rather episodic-like memory
in birds, has been also
applied to cuttlefish.
And I won't describe
all the details
of the experimental
design, which
was very clever and subtle,
but the upshot of it
was that it appears that
cuttlefish do have the ability
to remember not just
facts like this food
can be found there, but
facts of the form I was
at this location
an hour ago and ate
or I was at this other location
two hours ago and didn't eat.
So a sense of kind of not just
sort of facts about the world,
but facts about what I have
done and where I have been.
So this I find especially
enticing because things
like this, there's
just no chance
that was present in the
common ancestor of us
and these animals.
So independently, the
same kind of sense
of a self-behaving
in time appears
to have arisen in
several different lines.
AUDIENCE: What do we know
about the visual processing
in these animals?
You said that the eye is quite
similar to the human eye.
Does the animal have a similarly
organized visual cortex?
PETER GODFREY-SMITH:
Not similarly.
In general, once you
get past the eye,
everything becomes
different in these animals.
I'm not that knowledgeable about
the neurophysiology of vision
in octopuses.
I can certainly tell
you where to look.
One of the labs that
specializes in this
is Benny Hochner's lab at
Hebrew University in Jerusalem.
They're probably the
leading lab with respect
to the project of
trying to work out
how different the
organizational properties are
of an octopus' brain and ours.
And one thing that
they're looking at
and have sort of made
some claims about
is the idea that
within our brains,
you have quite a number of
sort of map-like structures
where the sort of sensory
array on the body maps
to sort of adjacent or
neighbor [INAUDIBLE] neurons
in the brain and that seems
to be absent in octopuses.
And you might think,
oh, right, that has
some linked to the
idea that there's too
many degrees of freedom to
control centrally so you leave
that stuff to the arms.
Or it might have some other
explanation, I don't know.
But his papers will be
the ones to look at.
AUDIENCE: It's really nice to
see an actively researching
scientist not deflationist about
subjective experience, that's
pretty refreshing.
But I just wanted to say
you were getting at our very
linear view on what
conscious experience is
like as potentially clouding
our view on what it can be
and how to fit it into
a scientific worldview,
but you didn't really flesh out
what sort of future research
program you had in
mind for the types
of different
organizations of, say,
like sea-like cells for
the future of fitting
subjective experience into
the scientific kind of canon.
So what sort of research
program for solving
the Chalmers-style hard
problem do you envision?
PETER GODFREY-SMITH: OK.
That's a very big
question, indeed.
And my answer would
be sort of so many
pronged that it's sort
of hard to organize it
in a brief reply.
But let me say a couple of
things just very quickly.
One is I think that with respect
to the sorts of challenges
that people like Chalmers
make, some of that
should be treated in a more
critical way where you say,
no, this kind of
barrier is not real
or this problem for a
materialist view is not real.
So I think a first move
that one should make
is to reorient our
thinking about the problem
in a way that's more
critical about the sort
of imaginable separability of
the mental and the physical,
the basis for the arguments
of Chalmers and others.
So criticize that.
Then choose the right
thing to explain.
And I think the right
thing to explain
is not sort of consciousness
as the sort of first target
or what's also often referred
to as qualia, the kind
of raw feel of experience.
But subjectivity,
that's the right target.
How is it that some physical
systems can comprise subjects
that have a point of view?
Once you understand that
and where they came from,
I think it will be
possible to explain
subjective experience
as something
that happens to subjects.
Now, how can we give
a scientific road
into the understanding of
subjectivity in a sense that's
relevant to that question?
Here I think there are lots
of things to think about.
I mean, giving a talk at
Google, it's very tempting
to say something about
attempts to come up
with artificial systems
that are relevant.
And I think what evolution
had to do that was a big deal
in this area was take quasi
autonomous cells that can sense
and signal and interact in
certain ways and that have
a kind of subject-like status
in a very minimal sense
on their own and coordinate
them such that the sort of proto
subjectivity of those
parts becomes sort of--
subsumed might not be
quite the right word,
but it'll do for now--
into the subjectivity of
the collective that results.
I think classical
AI did not think
about the problem
like that at all
and even contemporary
robotics tends
to start from a more sort of
straightforwardly centralized
organization.
And I certainly think it will
be intriguing to sort of think
about the problem via the same
path by which evolution thought
about the problem,
which is unity
and collectivity with respect
to systems of that kind.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
It's been a great talk.
So-- oh sorry.
PETER GODFREY-SMITH:
That's fine.
Please go ahead.
AUDIENCE: OK.
A lot of what I've been reading
about intelligence from sort
of a neuroscience point
of view seems to me
to lead in the direction of
saying that intelligence as we
understand it is sort
of irreducibly social.
I mean, I think the
signaling aspect
and this idea of a
sense of self coming out
of a model of others.
And so I'm intrigued because
it seems that these animals are
capable of very, very
complex signaling,
but also you said
they're not very social.
So I wonder how much do you
think their intelligence is
social, is engaged in signaling
and sensing the other animals.
PETER GODFREY-SMITH: I think for
the most part, cephalopod are
a lesson pushing against those
highly socialized conceptions
of intelligence that are very
popular in many theoretical
domains at the moment.
So I mean, as a philosopher
much of the time,
there are some philosophers
who emphasize this sort of
to and fro of sociality and
there are some philosophers who
emphasize the richness of
the individual's experience
and of particularity.
And cephalopods are sort
of with the second group,
they're with William James, a
sort of individualist style.
And I think that's just
something we learn from them.
We learn that by means of
some kind of combination
of the challenges of living
the lives they live where
they're soft-bodied, they're
prey for anything of a decent
size in the sea,
they're also predators--
they have to get around,
they have to be continually
exploring and looking for food--
and with their bodies that are
both so rich with possibility
but so hard to
control, I think we
learned that and
that's enough just
to build a very big and
complex nervous system.
Once you have that big and
complex nervous system,
it appears that if you
put a bunch of them
together in an unusually high
density setting, they all--
here I'm going beyond what I can
back up scientifically so I'm
being very speculative.
I think a lot of the
signaling behaviors
that we see at Octopolus,
the site in Australia,
are a kind of
improvised sociality.
I think the animals
sort of work out a way
with their general
cleverness to interact
in ways that are not too sort
of destructive and chaotic.
So I think they are sort
of a case on that side.
Just while we're talking about
the ways in which they push
against the familiar ways
of talking about or thinking
about the advantages in
evolutionary terms of having
a large brain and
high intelligence,
the other weird thing
about these animals
is their lives are so short.
An octopus is dead
usually within two years,
which is astounding.
So in two years, they kind of
rush through their early stages
and acquire quite a
large body in many cases.
Even the giant
Pacific octopus, which
is several hundred pounds of
octopus, that can live often
to about four years,
but that's about it
and that's the biggest
octopus of the species known.
No one knows the lifespan of
the giant squid, the really
colossal squid, but it's thought
to be of the same kind of order
of five years or so.
So they rush through their
lives and that would normally
be thought to be something that
tells against the advantage
of developing a large brain.
All that learning, you've got
no time to put it to any use.
So it just compounds
the puzzle in many ways.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
this very interesting talk.
So what do you think about the
correlation between parenting
and intelligence?
Because octopi do have
kind of parenting.
PETER GODFREY-SMITH: Not of
the sort that should help.
That's sort of the perfect--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it is
some kind of parenting.
When you care about your young--
PETER GODFREY-SMITH:
Only about the eggs.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PETER GODFREY-SMITH:
So this is exactly
the right sort of next
puzzle to sort of mention
after the previous
gentleman's questions.
So in many animals
that are smart,
you have significant
parental care
and the guidance of
the next generation
along the first steps.
With octopuses in general,
I'll mention an exception
a couple of exceptions in a
moment, the general pattern
is the female octopus
lays some eggs
and she tends and
broods them and fans
them to get exactly the right
level of oxygen in the water
that they're interacting with.
And the eggs hatch
and the larvae
float away as plankton and
that's it and she never
sees them again.
So there's care in the sense
of the eggs are not abandoned.
Cuttlefish eggs, by
the way, are abandoned.
So the female
cuttlefish lays eggs
often on the underside of a
ledge and then just goes off
and those eggs will hatch.
They're much more larger
and better provisioned
than octopus eggs and
they're a bit more robust.
But when they hatch, the
parents are long gone--
dead, in fact.
And with octopuses,
there's a bit more care,
but not care that
you would think
would help with the sort of
intellectual side of life
very much.
Because once the eggs hatch,
the larvae just become plankton.
Now, there are a few
exceptions where the larvae
may at least settle locally.
The larvae are larger when
the eggs hatch and don't just
float away and become plankton.
Not very much is
known about them.
There are a few sort of
larger-eyed octopuses.
But I think in
general, the picture
is if you're an octopus, from
the day that you're hatching
from the egg, you're
pretty much on your own
and your days are numbered.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
the tree structure of life
and you mentioned in some
cases there are junctions.
I wonder if you could
mention an example of this.
PETER GODFREY-SMITH: Right.
So once you get to
animals, genuine junctions
tend not to occur.
But in single-celled
life, so in bacteria,
you have a quite
different shape.
I mean, the tree metaphor
or the tree model
doesn't apply particularly
well to bacteria.
They're continually exchanging
bits and pieces of DNA
in a kind of freeway.
The eukaryotic cells
that make up our bodies
are the products
of an event where
one ancient prokaryotic
cell essentially swallowed
another and the two of them
came to live as a unit.
So that's a kind of
merging in the tree where
all the cells in your body are
descended from a merging event
that took place probably
perhaps something like 1.8
billion years or so ago.
So if you think about the tree
of life in a more exact way,
you should think
that it's a network.
The network in its old and
unicellular domains or regions
has a sort of a somewhat
haphazard not really tree-like,
but more complex structure.
And in some groups,
especially animals,
the thing sort of evolves
into a more definite tree
where you have
two-way branchings
and few or no rejoicings.
So the full picture
is not quite a tree,
but we animals, we form
a pretty good tree.
OK.
There's time for one more if
anyone would like to pop up.
AUDIENCE: So you
had an illustration
of the common ancestor of
the octopus and mammals.
From my perspective when
I look at an octopus,
it seems to have a lot of
similarities with mammals just
in terms of the
level of advancement
and complexity and
some things like you
mentioned the design of
the eye are quite similar.
How much of that
do you think was
latent in the DNA
versus how much of that
was truly independent because
it was required in the same way?
Do you think that there
were independent mutations
in the DNA that were
independently selected for?
PETER GODFREY-SMITH:
It's a very good question
and the word you
used, latent, I think
is exactly the right
way to ask the question.
So you have some
similarities of design
in the present coming
from something that looks
very different in the past.
And there's a school
of thought in biology
that I think would
answer your question
with a kind of emphatic yes.
They'd say, oh, yeah, right.
They look very
different, but there
was a kind of
architecture that was
kind of latent in a way in the
first bilaterally symmetrical
animals with a certain
kind of head to tail axis,
a certain organization
of the relationship
between the nervous
system and the rest.
And you know you should
think of the subsequent
unfolding down the two
lines as just variations
on a theme in a way and a
theme that was set down early.
That's one kind of
school of thought.
I'm describing this
a bit metaphorically,
I think it's clear in this case.
Then there is another,
and in some ways
more traditional school of
thought, that says, look,
evolution can do anything it
pretty much wants with bodies.
And you start with
something very simple,
and the fact that you have
certain similarities here
and here means that natural
selection disfavored
similar things and there were
mutations occurring quite
independently, quite
different in character
that built a similar structure.
Now, in the case of
having an eye with a lens,
the second view is
certainly right.
So there's no sense in
which the eye lens was
latent in the common ancestor.
And octopus lenses
and vertebrate lenses
are built from different stuff,
they have a different role.
So one distorts and one moves.
So camera lenses don't
distort, they move.
Some animal lenses distort, they
change shape, and some of them
move.
But the presence
of an eye at all
in the animal, forget the lens
and the particular structure,
but just whether you have
light sensitive things
roughly where they are,
plenty of biologists
think oh, yes, that
was probably laid down
and it's not something that
was independently invented,
it's something that
was laid down one time.
So I mean, my
expertise, such as it
is, is such that I can't
give a sort of richer
answer to the question than
that because what you're putting
your finger on there is a part
of biology which is intensely
and actively debated
and there are
different reasonable positions.
OK.
It's about five to.
Natural to wrap up
right about now?
OK.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]